welcome to this video playing psychic
I've got black again psychic an ok let's
go for some Queens gambit or in this
case the red team who is this guy who
say Ruslan yeah I played him Pletcher
only summers some like a week or so ago
I think it was a draw that I don't
remember that game gathered system what
we had line but quite interesting White
has his own structure entirely I mean
completely wrecked but he says that ok
I've got a bishop pair and what what do
you have yeah I've got the pawn yeah so
let's see what happens one one thing is
that the a4 square can be a good outpost
and I'm getting this right to work so
what's this to see does he get that pawn
ha that's not so great I wouldn't want
that seems to be
anyway I cannot I cannot allow them to
capture on b7 and this is not really
ideal it's not ideal at all let's see
here can i how do I get some kind of
counter play here and then eat oh I need
to disturb him a little bit check he has
it castle this is the only thing that my
position has going for it and try to be
a nuisance they're still cannot castle
how do I continue though I mean okay we
have to see what he's doing something
like Bishop f3 i can go Queen h3 and
store and be a pest i RK that sir that's
a good move I guess hmm ok g7 hangs
I mean sorry g7 Hanks if i move the
night this is what i was trying to say
yeah i can go if I if I wonder yeah
let's do we five if it takes with the
bishop rookie aid this looks fairly
dangerous so I don't think he can take
but you can cancel short of course yeah
that's okay actually I'm i also have
picture p 3 as a threatened and stuff
wow really why is this possible I
thought that was impossible okay so
rookie eight how do you play now deform
maybe deform it looks well okay you can
play that d 497 I'm probably not winning
straightaway maybe night for step better
okay wait wait wait if I go
94 and anyway I need to play a move him
97 was my original intention but this
looks better
yeah 35 why not g5 let's do it age 30 I
don't get it if you move the bishop
somewhere i take f3b sugar sequin a3s
Wow ok ok ok ok ok
such better no okay yes because some the
bishop move just about okay so f 54 f 4
after f3 the bishop is also hanging so
that's probably not helping a great deal
okay wow I'm not sure where what's
better king of Twiggy 30 f for the
iphone is probably stronger
yes this intermediate check is this a
big idea on j/k move first he can castle
now huh this is saving him Bishop g5 for
Bishop f6 hmm maybe I should have gone
to age five maybe time morning
ah oh it was such an interesting game
and that probably had some some
opportunities that I didn't take and
didn't use
yeah six pawns yeah I'm one point down
still no that's two pawns trying to do
something against as king yeah that
seems to be the the best chance check
and this time situation check check
check rah Alfred grass i'll share it I
cannot really escape it all no gain
drawn and its really a draw ok cannot
you cannot play for win because I'm too
active probably yeah I'd like to see if
I had some some chance that you win I
found that very risky to take that pawn
and deform nah doesn't seem to be a win
not you form yeah white white can castle
am but this really g five gigs here this
is a very interesting position do I have
something better than what i did i
played this that brutal f5 move the
engine wants to play Queen age three and
gives black a slight advantage
Queen h5 s bet I am this is the line
that the computer is giving chechik and
now I have this move yes check yeah this
looks kind of nice actually I mean I'm a
porn down but we shouldn't forget that
this is essentially date upon which is
not not worth anything and there are
some tempt Excel like oops like like
this this this one yeah that's very
George actually a very interesting her
interesting game the way it went check
he's certainly much much better d5 not
was a good opportunity but I understand
that you wanted to castle yeah this is
this is probably someone losing at d5 a
strong for Queen D for check yeah just
try to somehow go near the king and yeah
after that it is a draw funny enough h4
is still better for white yeah but this
is kind of difficult to to really I mean
you can analyze this but it's not really
relevant for blitz game as a 30 seconds
don't allow for really really good play
what about the REM tense game thanks for
watching